okay so getting back into donnie kate's
hulk run right picking up where we left
off and we'll kind of explain what's
going on to a degree as we go through
this as we usually do just because of
the fact that we're doing these like a
month apart we basically pick up in this
alternate universe with this alternate
reality version of bruce banner and we
pick up with this alternate reality
version of general thunderbolt ross now
there is this really really amazing
monologue that the that banner does like
the the main marvel universe banner the
incredible hulk does as all this is
happening because remember he's
basically
fighting this alternate reality version
of spider-man who was also exposed to
gamma radiation so like spider hulk
essentially and what he says here is he
says he wanted to be so much more than
this right he wanted to push the
boundaries explore the unknowable that
he wanted to discover and invent to
create instead on this world every world
that has ever known the name bruce
banner the story is always the same like
this alternate me the banner of this
world once said i am become death again
and again and again the destroyer of
worlds now i love that quote i don't
know where how many of you guys know
where that's from but it's it actually
comes from a from a hindu scripture but
it was really it really became a staple
of pop culture because of robert
oppenheimer after the detonation of the
atomic bomb when it was experimented
witnessing the first detonation um in
1945 after the manhattan project he said
i remember the line from the hindu
scripture the bhagavad-gita vishnu is
trying to persuade the prince that he
should do his duty and to impress him
takes on his multi-armed form and says
now i am become death the destroyer of
worlds i absolutely love that quote i've
always loved that quote right it's one
of my absolute favorite quotes when it
comes to the the history just just in
general right it's just it's an amazing
quote but nonetheless right this
alternate reality version of bruce is
basically being pummeled by thunderbolt
ross now remember they kind of worked
together to a degree right that ross
seemingly in this universe and virtually
every other has never really liked bruce
banner but the the i guess maybe
alliance between the two despite it
being tenuous was predicated on the idea
that in the attempt of this alternate
reality version of banner to solve the
biowaste problem and accidentally
creating all these different versions of
of hulks essentially some of whom are
grotesquely mutated others are
relatively normal in terms of their
appearance that
in order to correct this mistake they
would basically send them through a
wormhole and who knows where they would
go now one of the things donnie kate
tells us is that ultimately we'll find
out where they go to
we'll find out where it is that they all
end up at but regardless it's just this
really really cool moment because what
ross wants here in basically pummeling
this alternate reality version of banner
is he wants to know what this hulk is
where it came from and how to kill it
and that's the crazy thing is because
this version of hulk this alternate
reality hulk represents this huge threat
to this alternate version of thunderbolt
ross because it could destabilize
everything he's built now remember in
terms of how the incredible hulk
operates right now it's the incredible
hulk's strength that is basically
motivated by the incredible hulk itself
that what you have here is you have
banner who controls the mind of the
incredible hulk and that he basically
forces the incredible hulk psyche to
face off against all these different
threats and as you guys know the longer
a fight goes on for and the more
difficult it becomes for the incredible
hulk to defeat a foe the angrier the
incredible hulk becomes and the angrier
the hulk becomes the stronger he becomes
so quite literally bruce banner has
turned the incredible hulk persona into
a source of power that he can manipulate
right he can literally ramp it up by
stages ramp it down by stages have him
face off against all kinds of credible
threats and so the result of this is
right now they're at stage four
basically the incredible whole persona
is fighting marvel zombies in his own
mind and because the incredible hulk
cannot differentiate right it's
basically a child it doesn't know that
what it's seeing is not real it thinks
it is and so it's just pummeling
everything it sees and as the fight
continues to go on the incredible hulk
persona gets angrier and angrier and
gets stronger and stronger and so
because of this again betty ross has
intermittently kind of appeared in the
mind of banner and just kind of talked
to him occasionally and one of the
things that she says is she asked like
what are you doing right like you know
you're not going to kill that poor thing
and the responsive banner is i mean like
what are you talking about and the
answer that betty offers is like he's
just a child right he can't help what he
is and that's when banner gets a little
irritated and just kind of like you know
what is this right since when do you
care so much about protecting these
supposed children why is this so
important to you and that's when when
betty's like bruce i don't exist right
i'm not a i'm a manifestation of your
own mind but she says i know what
happens when you lock a child away and
abuse it when you take its freedoms away
it's agency it bottles all of that up
right all of that fury all of that rage
when you do that bruce the child turns
into what made it you know this better
than anyone you were turned into what
you are by your father right like you
hurt people you did bad things to people
right like the incredible hulk persona
is a manifestation of the abuse you
experience at the hands of your father
right rage given a physical form and she
says now you have to ask yourself if you
lock the hulk away and you keep hurting
it keep making it angrier making it
bottle up all of that rage when that
child explodes what will he turn into
and the responsive manner is i don't
know but let's find out and that's when
he ramps it up to stage five in order to
defeat this you know mutated version of
spider-man and at this point now it's
fighting gods it's fighting cerner and
like thor and beta ray bill and like
loki and all these people which again
makes the hulk angrier and angrier now
the hulk is able to overcome this uh
this this mutated spider you know spider
hulk he's able to overcome him but at
that point or at least uh kind of get
the fight to the point where spider
spider hulk is on the ropes but what you
do here is you basically switch over to
this alternate reality version of banner
and it says like i tried to tell you
everything like i've told you everything
i know right like there's no conceivable
way that i know of to kill this version
of the incredible hulk and that's when
you end up having uh having thunderbolt
ross who lays his chips on the on the
table right he tells he tells the guys
to leave and he basically reveals his
hand and what he says here is that in
reality uh at the end of the day when it
came to like all these different
versions of the hulk that this alternate
reality version of banner had
accidentally created the general
thunderbolt ross wasn't just getting rid
of them indiscriminately that what he
was doing was actually weaponizing them
that the ones who were weaker the ones
who couldn't serve a useful purpose they
were all discarded they were sent to the
portal to end up wherever it was that
they ended up at but the reality is the
ones who were stronger the ones who
could be used for warfare right that
they were kept and in fact reed richards
in this alternate universe had actually
made it possible for thunderbolt ross to
essentially control these versions of
the hulk and then in turn they've used
them to fight wars right now one of the
things that thunderbolt ross has said is
that he had to use the ordinance that's
the equivalent to the gdp of multiple
nations that have been conscripted or
taken over by the us so what this means
and what this seems to indicate is that
the geopolitical landscape is not the
way that it is in the main marvel
universe it's not the united states of
america canada mexico russia any of the
number of countries that are in europe
right china that instead things seem to
have changed drastically and we don't
necessarily know what what continents or
what nations the united states has taken
over but the united states has taken
over a lot of them right they they seem
to control a huge part of the world and
the incredible hulks that were basically
being taken by uh by thunderbolt ross
that had accidentally been created by
banner they were instrumental in making
that happen and so while it's not
necessarily the fault of banner
thunderbolt ross plays it off by saying
in a way it is like you sure like all
these incredible hulks they were an
accident created by you it wasn't your
intention you were just trying to solve
the biowaste problem but you literally
gave us weapons and while i never told
you before i used them to win wars right
i just kind of kept it hidden from you
and so that's the crazy thing is because
what happens is that in the middle of
all this you have the fight going on
between hulk and and you know spider
hulk in the actual real world right
that's where that fight is taking place
but the reality is all these bombs are
dropped by thunderbolt ross right and
when that happens it's not enough to
kill spider hulk or anything but it's
certainly enough to basically destroy
the visor of of banner and when that
happens like banner is like literally
the whole thing goes nuts right like
banner's just kind of blown out of a
seat and all that kind of stuff and
while it is a little weird because
banner is supposed like this is the
physical body of the hulk so it's
basically the the the psyche of banner
the psyche of the incredible hulk
basically you know kind of operating
inside this body uh that banner is
actually overtaken by the psyche of
betty ross that the the kind of physical
representation we get here at least as
far as we can tell is basically banner
just kind of being thrown out there it's
not really banner being thrown into the
physical real world instead what it is
is it's actually banner just being
thrown out of control right that
basically betty ross is taking over
that's kind of how that works right so
those of you guys who are watching like
moon night right now for example you
know how like the the minds switch
between like steve grant and mark
spector this is the equivalent of when
like mark spector takes over and steve
grant ends up going back there but
instead of steve grant like really
relinquishing control uh mark spector
just takes control
that's basically how this is working
right now to give you guys a better
understanding of what's going on because
i know like on the surface just looking
at it it's like wait a minute okay so
like does banner physically exist no
it's basically just the betty ross
persona taking over the body of the
incredible hulk and forcing the bruce
banner persona into the background right
and so because of this what you also end
up learning here is that this isn't
actually betty ross it looks like it's
betty ross but it's not actually betty
ross right one of the things she says is
that where banner's begging right like
you have to help me here the the
response she gives is like look at you
right helpless trapped at the mercy of
forces and violence out of your control
remind you of anybody and and ultimately
she says you never really listen do you
right i told you bruce betty isn't real
betty's not here and what she does is
she ramps the engine up and basically
takes it to stage six and so now you
have the incredible hulk persona facing
off against demons mephisto dormamu
right all these different guys now
here's kind of a funny caveat to this
right here's something that you may not
have noticed one of the things that
donnie cates is doing is giving us a
hierarchy of power in marvel comics it's
very easy to miss it's very easy to not
notice but he's giving us a hierarchy of
power that in essence you have stage one
which is kind of a relatively small
threat but as the stages go up the
beings become more powerful it wouldn't
really make any sense to ramp the
incredible hulk up to stage six and then
like here comes the red skull it
wouldn't really make any sense to do
that
and so donnie kate's is in effect giving
us a hierarchy of power in the marvel
universe i can guarantee you people are
gonna reference this right you go and
you look at like battle forms and
different things like that or you ask
people you know in different forms like
who you know who's more powerful you
know like uh odin or or like dormammu
right people are gonna be like well i
mean according to donnie cases and you
know hulk run it looks like it's
dormammu because dormammu was a stage
six villain or stage six power and odin
was stage five you know and that kind of
a thing right but it's a cool little
aside here it's a it's a smart little
thing and so in the end one of the
things that happens is that general
thunderbolt ross reveals to uh bruce
spanner this alternate version of bruce
that these bombs that he dropped are not
bombs in the traditional sense instead
what they are here are basically a means
of mutation that what's happening is
that inside each one of these canisters
are basically people that had become
that had been mutated even though
unintentionally by banner but the ones
that thunderbolt ross had kept and that
these as thunderbolt rosso first uh
refers to them are basically just like
abominations right kind of like this
alternate reality version of abomination
here and so it's nuts because these
things are massive in size right they're
absolutely huge in size and so of course
this basically leads to betty completely
taking over the body of the incredible
hulk completely pushing banner's persona
out of the way but in doing so she says
but i'm proud of you son and that's
where it seems to hit this idea that
this is potentially brian banner now
this is where things get a little murky
because in al ewing's ron one of the
things to remember in the immortal hulk
is that it wasn't necessarily brian
banner it kind of was but it was
basically brian banner's spirit or
essence that had been overtaken by the
one below all and used to torment the
incredible hulk that's what that was it
wasn't actually brian banner himself and
so what this does is it builds on what
we've seen both in al ewing's runs a lot
of runs that came before it bill mantlo
peter david we're basically the brian
banner persona is kind of the uh the
controlling aspect now that's me
guessing here right just going on what's
sort of happening in terms of words that
brian banner is the source of bruce
banner's torment and seemingly the most
powerful entity in his mind the one
thing that banner just can't seem to
overcome but i could be entirely wrong
here this could very well be the the
mental persona of the titan hulk right
like we don't know we won't know until
we get to the next issue but ultimately
that this persona ends up ramping
everything up right like right past
stage seven and and right past stage
eight all the way to stage nine which is
basically just who really even knows
what this stage looks like presumably
it's the titan hulk but whatever it is
it literally leads to the incredible
hulk just absolutely
losing it and annihilating all these
different abomination forces that are
out there and that's where it ends so
presumably this is where titan hulk
comes into play and if it does
i can't wait to see how this plays out
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace